when we did our analytic analysis of the
constraint conditions between the
accelerations of objects 1 & 2 we came
up with a condition that a 1 was equal
to minus 2 a 2 now let's do something
which we call a virtual displacement
argument suppose that B and to move down
a certain amount let's imagine and I'm
gonna draw it in a different color too
so we have object 2 and pulley 2 has
moved down now this object has displaced
by a distance Delta y2 which is also
equal to Delta YB because they're
connected now what happens when the
system does that is our rope has to
extend downwards around this pulley and
come back up and that means that the
rope that object 1 has been
foreshortened by not just Delta Y 2 but
on both sides Delta Y 2 and Delta Y 2
object 1 has displaced up by that amount
so we'll just make this so we can draw
it in a reasonable way so what we see
here is that Delta Y 1 is equal to now
notice if 2 goes down Y by Delta Y 2
then Delta Y 1 which is this whole
distance is a negative quantity and it's
going upwards and so we see that that's
minus 2 Delta Y 2 and if we took two
derivatives or displacement and then
look at the change in displacement we
would see that this implies that the
acceleration of 1 is minus 2 a 2 but
let's come back to our two conditions
for length and see the same thing here
because Delta L 2 is 0 this tells us
that Delta Y 2 is equal to Delta YB so
we'll write minus equals 0 and that was
our condition that to the block and to
our
moving together and up here we see that
because Delta L 1 is also 0 this implies
and now I'll make that substitution that
Delta YB is equal to Delta Y 2 that to
Delta Y 2 here and here plus Delta Y 1
has to be 0 coming from that piece and
so we see that Delta Y 1 is minus 2
Delta Y 2 which is what our virtual
displacement argument showed us and
again if you take two derivatives here
we have that recall that in the simplest
way that the velocity is d y1 DT and the
acceleration a1 is d squared y 1 DT
squared then the same proportionality is
maintained under the two derivatives and
that's another way of thinking about how
to get the relationship between
accelerations but you have to be
extremely careful about that sign
because as 2 goes in the positive
direction one will go in the negative
direction